as we countdown to Monday special
broadcast from the Smithsonian National
Museum of african-american history and
culture four days and Counting now we'll
bring you the stories behind the
exhibitions a gallery on the third floor
called power of place we'll explore
areas in the US with a distinct African
American identity one of those places is
a small New England town on the island
of Martha's Vineyard Margaret Brennan
shows us how Oak Bluffs became a popular
retreat visited by President Obama and
many others the charming New England
cottages of Martha's Vineyard have been
a summer getaway for the African
American elite for more than a hundred
years drawn to the harbors of Oak Bluffs
in the late 1800s freed slaves and
laborers began settling there Charles
share the son of a slave and her white
owner turned this cottage into the first
in for black vacationers sharers
great-granddaughter Lee Van Allen
african-americans came to visit and they
were not able to stay at the homes they
were not welcomed there because of
segregation so he was our business
opportunity and he opened then share a
cottage the cottage soon attracted the
African American elite including actor
Paul Robeson singer Ethel Waters and
composer Harry T Burleigh so it really
was the beginning of the expansion of
the African American community on
Martha's Vineyard Adam Clayton Powell
jr. one of the first african-american
congressman writer Dorothy West and
Ralph mishit Coleman considered the Dean
of Boston's black theatre purchased
homes nearby today they're featured
along the islands african-american
Heritage Trail historians Elaine
Weintraub and Cary tankard founded it
why is the sheer house the first stop on
this tour we felt that the contribution
is made to the islands history should be
celebrated first we had an ambitious
plan Carrie you know that we have
foresight 26:26 thank you and the
Smithsonian took notice the community
and the work of Charles share will be
featured at the National Museum of
african-american history and culture
it's dated 1878 seventy-nine author
Jessica Harris donated artifacts from
her family's historic home
why did you think it was important to
make a donation to the exhibit things
are changing this is not the oak left I
grew up in but as it changes through
things through artifacts one can
maintain a connection with the past
these days the african-american
community here on Martha's Vineyard has
expanded beyond Oak Bluffs the bottom
line is whatever anybody says one way or
the other the nucleus the bedrock the
beating heart and soul of the
african-american community on this
island is and will always be a plus for
CBS this morning Margaret Brennan Oak
Bluffs Massachusetts people who live in
Edgartown and vineyard haven other
places might disagree but oak plus is a
very special place because they say you
know we've got soul we've got a beating
heart that's what I Marco that's what I
mean it's a yeah we have something
offered to it's just a great great place
I hold vineyard I love it